boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about social
impact tech we have Shannon Farley and
Kevin barenblatt joining us on the show
hello hi thanks for having us thank you
so much for coming on I love your work
I'm so excited for this show
Savion yeah and who shall I say Andrew
for introducing us I'm super grateful
for him for those that don't know Shanna
Farley and Kevin barenblatt are
cofounders of fast forward which
accelerates tech for social impact
they've accelerated 41 tech nonprofits
impacting 51 million lives so far and
you can find the links in the bio balota
f FWD F forward org
and then also the Twitter profile and
the LinkedIn profiles for Shannon and
Kevin both are you guys let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world I'm worried I feel that with
rising income inequality and the social
inequity the trails from that we have
big problems ahead of us and often our
focus is not on our biggest social
problems where probably should be I
think it depends on a little bit on
where you sit I think if you're a human
and you're born today in the lottery of
humanity chances are you might be better
off than you were 100
more years ago but if you're most any
other living thing on earth I might be
more worried and if the earth itself
think I would also be they worried about
the impact that we're having on the
planet
the times are both incredible and
they're also really a lot of challenges
they're facing us and sometimes we talk
about this on the show that in Silicon
Valley are we focused on the most
pressing challenges on the planet or are
we doing these incremental tiny things
for the elite already and how do we also
ethically evolve ourselves to be able to
see that better and to be able to help
so that wherever you're birthed into the
lottery that you have equality of
opportunity to pursue what drives you
what is your North Star and how yeah
yeah so that's something that we love
talking about a lot and I'm glad that
you guys brought that up it's good
because the inspiration for fast-forward
in fact because about six years ago when
I met Shannon I was I'm an entrepreneur
it's the most of my life as a
entrepreneur and I was looking around
trying to figure out what company I was
smart and spending a lot of time with
other entrepreneurs and I was really
impressed by how much progress
entrepreneurs here in the Bay Area can
make with very little money and I'd meet
folks who had built like these amazing
solutions but it wasn't clear what
problems they were solving these are
like photo apps and dog babysitting
daycare or things you know it's like
here we are in a world surrounded by
five problems and it was frustrating to
me that we didn't having resources for
folks who really wanted to be mission
driven and start first with the problem
what led you both to this realization so
what are your journeys leading up to
fast forward that got you guys excited
about where you're at now I started my
career in nonprofits I first helped
start prison reform group in the early
2000s and later I went and ran a global
Women's Fund and that Women's Fund in
particular was sort of like an early
stage tech nonprofit it was a
decentralized voting mechanism for us to
pool donations and distribute them to
women around the world and we did all of
the voting on a wiki it was completely
democratized and it was really exciting
but we had all of the problems that the
technology forward supports have and
that we were working on social issues
and applying tech to it but there were
very few funders who understood the
model there were very there were no
founder communities at the time where
you could gather with other social
entrepreneurs who were thinking about
how you apply tech to big social
problems and it was nascent and hard and
lonely and so I have deep empathy for
the groups that we work with so I was
really interested in how do you apply
the best technology to the biggest
social problems and create the dynamics
in which that's possible and I was lucky
enough to go to a party and I sat next
to Kevin and he had a different journey
but we ended up at the same spot I came
to California from Texas because I
wanted to be engineer I thought
engineers helped and tech could solve
problems and around the time that I met
Jen and on my entrepreneurial journey I
was a recovering addict eliezer I never
grew up wanting to become an optimizer
but I feel like that's where so much no
one dreams of being an addict advisor
but yet so much of our attention and
energy
just put into things like optimization
so for me I was looking to something
very very different and that's when I
went out talking to other other folks
looking for inspiration but instead I
feel like I sort of found frustration
because I was really impressed with how
far entrepreneurs could get with very
little money but not with the problems
that they set out to tackle and what was
different from other times that I'd
started out on the entrepreneurial
journey was how easy it was actually to
start a company in a tech company in
particular because the cost of starting
them had come down so much that it
opened up a new kind of opportunity a
new market opportunity if you will to
solve not just business problems but
actually social problems to you guys are
like the embodiment of actually tackling
social problems and not and you
leveraging the best tech for that and
trying to funnel in the right resources
human talent as well and monetary
resources yeah yeah that's you speak
your you walk the talk you do which is
it's great that you guys found each
other to embark on it together so then
okay so that's six years ago you find
each other didn't bark on this and then
what is it like then in the process of
starting fast-forward figuring out how
you're gonna raise money identify the
right social impact entrepreneurs how
does that process work we borrowed a
playbook from Silicon Valley so around
the time I met Jen I've been going to a
lot of demo days we wanted to take that
same model where you bring a group of
really inspiring passionate people
together for a few months time to work
on their ventures and then bring in
support speakers trainers mentors
mentors capital resources in order to
set them on the right path to be a
successful
and so we borrowed that same approach
for which there are thousands of
accelerators for for-profits but not for
nonprofits I say our backgrounds really
matter because we're both entrepreneurs
even though we're working in different
sectors so we met in the fall and
decided to do this in December and the
first class launched in June it was a
very quick on-ramp to doing this thing
and so we had to go find technology
when we started we really only knew five
for being honest we knew it we knew of
the household names like Wikipedia and
Khan Academy and kiba and then we get
stuck so we had to go find really
exciting technology
we needed to find people who we thought
could give them access to networks they
wouldn't otherwise have access to
information they may not have seen yet
and by merging our two worlds we were
able to create ecosystem of support for
these teams and in many ways now that
we're bigger now that we know really
every tech nonprofit in the world so far
we still have that same approach how do
you think about merging the social
sector and the tech sector to have
exponential impact on these kinds of
organizations interesting so the amount
of teknon profits that that are also
doing social impact so it has to be that
both yes for us they have to be solving
problems that markets won't solve
because you're reaching this hardest to
reach customer or you're working in a
space which there may be a for-profit
competitor but you're serving a
different customer okay and they have to
be building technology so it's not just
a nonprofit organization that maybe is
using email or a CRM system they're
really using the technology to effect
the impact okay and then so whoo yeah so
then you you ended up finding five in
the first batch it was okay so you found
these five techniques you incubated them
then under the Fast ForWord
accelerator okay and then you had high
quality mentors a high quality like kind
of like a rigorous
system for helping them develop out
their projects
I'll further because these entrepreneurs
have all the challenges that many
entrepreneurs are familiar with the tech
startups have they also face the
challenges of nonprofits and so
providing them the skills and resources
to navigate those challenges is critical
for them to be able to to break out as
stars and have the impact that they want
to have you know almost all of our
entrepreneurs have personal experience
with the problem that they set out to
solve and so many of them grew up with
phones in their pockets and so when they
grow up wanting no-one else to
experience the same problems that they
had they obviously looked the technology
that they carry around with them every
day as part of that solution and so then
give us and some of the examples of
companies that have been coming through
these are in it's about six month
periods right of acceleration it's just
three months it's a three month period
so then you do how many batches every
year of companies just one batch year
one batch there's someone just over 500
tech nonprofits around the world and
we've now had 41 go through the program
okay so it's still it's a MASINT oh
there's only 500 tech nonprofits in the
world there may be some more but yeah
that's basically you know so far yeah
but everyone that's watching this show
now can send us the ones they know about
and then the companies yeah everyone
watching send it fast forward yeah a
patek nonprofits from around the world
and then then they have to fly to San
Francisco they have to be incubated
locally for the three-month period that
was one of our findings you know in
traditional Silicon Valley accelerators
you force founders to come to Silicon
Valley and move here and live here be it
merged in Silicon Valley culture for
ours most of our founders don't come
from the Bay Area anymore they come from
other places and it was far more
equitable to allow them to fly in and
out every couple of weeks this is one of
the reasons we have far more female
founders it's why we have more founders
with experience of the problem it makes
it possible for them to be in this space
and take what they learn here back home
okay
gotcha so it doesn't permanently have to
be here those three months come in learn
engage bring back what you learn out to
the communities that you're residing in
and that also gives flexibility for
women then as well families the type of
stuff yeah exactly we originally thought
we started fast forward that the easiest
way to scale would be to launch this in
New York or London or Delhi or Shanghai
in different places around the world
that can really where they're
entrepreneurs we're thinking about how
they can leverage tech to scale their
impact but it turns out that most
entrepreneurs who come to the program
feel like they've tapped out their local
networks and are in fact are super
excited to come here and experience the
magic of the Bay Area maybe like when
you moved here years ago yeah they do
want to come and experience what it's
like to be inside of the tech company
and walk the streets of San Francisco
and meet people at restaurants that are
all working in tech so that's actually
that's you know a important part of the
program so let's talk about the program
so what happens when you fight when you
identify the companies which I assume
takes a long time then to pick the right
ones and bring them in and then what do
they go through what is it a fast
forward acceleration program it's
training and everything a non-profit
would need and everything a tech startup
would need to get started so everything
from fundraising and ethics of
distribution to which be the nonprofit
side to for-profit speaking about growth
hacking thinking about architecture how
you would build your useful thing in the
world we also connect them with mentors
about a hundred from the tech and
philanthropic sector so by the time they
leave us they have their own network
that can help them scale their ideas we
also give them money which is a really
important part right the there are few
funders who understand technology many
are risk averse and nervous about
investing in early-stage organizations
so we give them general support money
and we help them raise additional funds
through our demo day programs okay and
what's the amount of seed funding that
you help them with we give them twenty
five thousand twenty-five thousand
dollars okay cool
and so then what would what are these
things that you're enlisting this like
ethics of distribution like what are
they what is this stuff as someone who's
been most of my career in the for-profit
space when I think of nonprofit I think
that it's just easy because like
everything is focused on impact there
aren't these other stakeholders to worry
about
there's no shareholders don't have to
worry about maximizing profits we can
just focus on impact but the reality is
even within a construct of a mission
alignment organization there's still
sometimes tough decisions to be made how
do you think about do you think about
impact is just maximizing the area of
the number of people served and how
you're serving them are you specifically
going after populations that no other
folks will go after and when you think
about in terms of technology there are
organizations let's say that creative
open source software so it's like look
we're just gonna make this available
anyone with the resources to use it and
leverage it can use that technology or
you could decide to have a more hands-on
approach like there with technology one
of the great things about tech is it
scales really well so it helps
organizations have bigger impact without
their costs also getting bigger but one
of the challenges is that like a lot of
the features that tech products build
can apply to a wide variety of audiences
and so if you're building tools for
patient you know for doctors and
hospitals or to teach kids to be better
leaders is that available to anyone are
you specifically going after a low
resource schools and these are all
ethical decisions which there is not
necessarily a right answer but then even
mission focus organizations have to make
these trade-offs about where they
allocate this
resources interesting okay so then as
you have this technologies individual
companies then they have this ethics of
distribution it's almost like a dilemma
of sorts you get to figure out where how
to adequately identify people that are
underserved and help them while also
being able to sustain the the project
itself so that's kind of an equilibrium
that needs to be you talk about that a
lot like once you decide who your core
customer is right the business model
follows from it so if you decide that
your Khan Academy and you want free
education for everyone
anywhere you have a particular kind of
business model versus a group that is
more interested in kids who are just
coming from schools that have most of
their children on free and reduced lunch
and there is a different business model
that goes to serving still a software
platform still a platform that is
teaching kids online but thinking about
the unique needs of that customer Khan
Academy can run Super Bowl commercials
and get sponsorships and funding from
foundations this smaller group that's
working on a niche customer they may be
working directly with school districts
and getting paid for access to the data
that they're get at gaming on the
students they may be paid also by
individual donors but there's there's
different kinds of earned revenue
strategies which is what we call it in
the nonprofit space but one of the
things about technology in particular is
they really lend themselves to licensing
models so we encourage folks to choose
first who do you want to serve I need to
be really clear on why you want to serve
that person or that issue area and then
you can sort of build the business model
around it it seems obvious but in some
in many ways it can be the opposite
order from what you might see inside for
profits where you see you start with the
product the solution and then you
segment your customers based on who's
the most profitable who's the easiest to
serve and that's where you focus your
organization's energy that's where the
80/20 rule comes from is that you can
get 80% of your profits
20% of the customers in the challenge
that many the organizations we work with
us mission impact oriented organizations
as they're trying to they're focusing on
the ones that are ignored there maybe
harder to reach harder to serve or the
ones who for whom the products haven't
yet been built and so they by starting
with the customer and then thinking
about their needs and the product it's
not just that the whole path can look
very different for that out there
they're often often less committed to
the type of solution right which as a
tech accelerator makes it really
exciting right like you can think about
how you pivot a product just best serve
that customer as opposed to I've built
this thing and now who the hell is going
to buy it ok and then let's go through
some of the examples there's been 41 of
these companies that have come through
you in the last six years so what like
yeah give us some of these examples
what is the detect that they made how
did you guys help accelerate it make
more social impact with it
I was excited for the stories one of our
best examples is common lit common lit
was started by a reading teacher in
rural Mississippi and her name is
Michelle Brown Michelle had like over a
dozen reading levels in her classroom
and a ton of kids and no books and you
know she is a bright ambitious person
she wanted to give each child the best
possible education and that's just not
easy to do when you have that many kids
and that many different reading levels
so she did at the time which was the
only thing available is she went to
Pinterest to find curricula for her
students and she thought that was crazy
so she gets out she goes to grad school
and this is when we meet her in the
story she had basically written herself
all the different curricula she would
need for her kids and she put it on PDFs
on a website she had had a small
crowdfunding campaign she'd raise like
around 30 thousand dollars from friends
and family and that was the beginning of
common lip well she goes through the
program fast forward within a year of
fast forward she was already served
400,000 kids today just a couple years
later she's serving 10 million kids well
yeah
around the u.s. and now increasingly in
Latin America and they take this great
content that's where they get royalty
free licenses from publishers like NPR
Sports Illustrated New York Times they
get teachers who have been vetted to
write the curricula and they provide
this resource that is always free for
teachers
hmm there are other for-profit products
on the market that provide digital
literacy curricula Pearson being the
biggest one but it's not free for
teachers mm-hmm so she was solving
Michelle was solving the problem she had
now their revenue model is they have a
paywall in which districts can get
insights on their kids but because
they're a non-profit they can remain
committed to making sure that teachers
always have access to the best possible
curricula very cool okay yeah I like how
that one works I like how the the
problem being solved of having it be
free of a literacy curriculum and then
also how there's a monetization strategy
that's still embedded within it so that
the district can get these insights on
the kids so that way there's still a way
for it to sustain and grow yeah okay
one of my favorites is Gavin mcCormick
it's the founder of what time with when
he was a PhD student at University of
California Berkeley he recognized that
he was studying energy in the
environment and there's information
available on the power grid that tells
you which power plant the energy are
pulling from the grid is coming from E
and right now every time we plug
anything into the power grid even if
we're super well-intentioned like let's
say I bought an electric car or electric
vehicle and I think I'm doing good for
the planet
there's a reasonable chance that your
electric vehicle was pulling dirty power
like from a coal or other power plants
and so what do you you did with that
insight was build software that would
actually only pull the power when it was
clean and giving people the power to
choose clean energy to help it scale he
doesn't need to build the software the
hardware he just provides the software
to other folks who are trying to make
smart batteries or smart thermostats and
what's super interesting about his
approach is rather than some of the
other better known social impact tech
organizations teknon profits like
Mozilla that open source their software
he's actually focused on miss emission
sourcing so it's not available to anyone
there's lots of ways people could use
the technology that he's developed in
that insight not all of its good you
could use it for arbitrage and energy
and make other things but anyone who
wants to use the technology to help the
environment who has a similar minded
mission is he's interested in partnering
with them to help bring it to
and so it's really interesting because
it's like a it's a really unique insight
from existing yeah software and
obstruction applying it to like a very
specific you case but then his his
approach to bringing it to market is
also very mission minded one of the
things that I think is really
revolutionary about what time is so much
of environmental justice work has been
around behavior change and they're sort
of leapfrogging the behavior change
piece by just putting the code on all
batteries you don't have to change how
people are using energy per se you just
make it easier to use clean energy yeah
excellent examples both of them so-so
okay so with common lit this is like
kids around the United States and now
Latin America and even more so hopefully
around the world
can gain have through their teachers
they can go and download common lit and
then these different partners that have
partnered with the nonprofit Sports
Illustrated what were the other ones
again New York Times runtime and EIA are
and then so then they provide a kind of
like a is it is it like reading material
based on my level of literacy so they
can provide like 5th grade reading
material or 10th grade reading you're a
seventeen year old but you're reading at
a third grade level you may be able to
read a Sports Illustrated article and
start to understand basic concepts
around sentence construction and verb
agreement but the third grade leaving a
little material is super not interesting
it's you know it's hard to engage those
students with a reading level
appropriate material that's maybe not
age-appropriate for their interest yeah
this and also this idea of like a
closed-loop feedback so like if the
students are slowly gaining literacy to
be able to adjust the difficulty of the
reading for that or decrease it if
they're having struggling with it and
it's real-time insight you know they
might be missing one concept and you can
see it and how they're tracking what
they're reading
so we should say it is no longer PDFs on
a website it's a full web platform that
allows you to actively track where a
student is in the moment that child
and flag things that maybe our are or
are not working mm-hmm and then with
what time - there's this we was talk
about the hundred billion people before
I said built civilization and one of the
main things that we get endowed with is
this abundant electricity is fantastic
but you don't actually know when you
plug something into a wall what it's
being where the power is coming from so
so how do I know that I'm if I am just
using an outlet how would I know where
it is coming from like how would that
work how would I gain the insight that
is coming from clean energy versus not
well time has the tool that's website
where you can type in your zip code and
it will give you a sense but one of the
challenges of why it's hard to do any
other way than in real time with
software is that it's actually
unpredictable so you know power isn't
stored on the grid the grid doesn't
store power and so the power utilities
need to fire up these eco unfriendly
power plants in order to meet demand
because the renewable green sources like
when the sun is shining and the wind is
blowing or sometimes hard to predict but
the thing about the real time making us
pulling the power building that
awareness into the devices themselves
means that when the Sun does shine of
the wind does blow and that extra excess
power becomes available on the grid you
can then charge your battery turn on
your air conditioning things that where
you need the power but it's not super
time-sensitive so my then just it's a
zip code based right now is on the
website under what device would actually
be reading from the outlet the smart
device so a smart car it said you're
would really it's not open to the
choices themselves any smart battery
HVAC systems like you can imagine these
huge energy guzzlers but that are latent
ly charging and the grid updates I
didn't know this until we met what time
the grid updates every few minutes mmm
so in this five minutes it could be
pulling coal in the next five minutes it
could be pulling wind and you're just
letting it charge while you're sleeping
yeah might as well pull the wind yeah
there was another
I forgot how long ago was that we spoke
to that was doing the only pulling from
the grid when it's sustainable as well
so this is a very important project I
like that one a lot I like common let a
lot these are very very good projects so
then so then what other examples of
technology of you guys brought in and
then what work are they doing socially
I'd love to learn more examples I think
the audience can get really inspired by
your examples one of our more recent
ones that we're particularly excited
about is called up solve up solve makes
it very simple to apply for Chapter
seven bankruptcy may not know this but
it's expensive to apply for bankruptcy
like two thousand bucks to get a lawyer
to process your documentation but if
you're that broke that you need to file
for bankruptcy you may not be able to
afford two thousand dollars and so what
upsold did is they digitized the legal
process and that they allow people to
apply for chapter 7 bankruptcy online
it's a powerful tool for legal justice
and in a very short amount of time ups
off has become the largest provider of
digital legal aid in the country largest
provided digital legal aid more than
LegalZoom and although they're ones
legal aid so meaning for indigent
clients yeah for the poor for poor folks
oh wow for legal aid yeah okay got it
large legal aid okay Wow
up solve okay okay
I'm not really a favorites person I have
a hard time picking favorites I think
there's so many that are doing such
incredible work I think one that we're
working with now that I'm really excited
about is open aq and what she's done is
she's taken air quality data actually
what she would call air inequality data
because it shows you how uncle area and
parts of the world and digitize it in a
single format so that researchers and
other folks around the world have better
access to the state of its and
inconsistent formats across the world so
she's taking data from over 160 sources
put it in one centralized place and has
tens of lands of API calls on her
platform every month for people who are
looking to try to understand how our
inequality affects health stat that
might surprise you one in eight humans
on the planet will die from error in
equality because the air we breathe
remember like last year when the air was
really bad in San Cisco from the fires
there's people who breathe air like that
every day millions billions of them
around the planet summer platform makes
that more easily accessible and then the
data helps drive change and it's being
used by citizen scientists and
journalists policy advocates to think
about policies that you could shift and
talk about publicly to make better air
quality it's already working they have
some examples in Mongolia and Beijing
we're simply having an air quality
sensor making the data public oh yeah
creeps an uprising and that's what's
required to make serious social change
yeah I think there was a project like
that for the speed at which the
temperature on the planner the parts per
million on the planet reader it was like
I don't remember it was like a four
fifteen point you know whatever out
numbers down to like maybe like six
decimal points down and you could just
see it just ticking up over time and so
it got people interested in like seeing
a real-time data feedback of decreasing
our carbon emissions on the planet and
that same thing can be done for yeah air
quality is a good one
open aq open air quality that's so good
and there think you gave this example
there's we even have a friend that's
starting to like carry around an air
quality reader and just like yeah just
literally just like be like oh it's you
know green here it's yellow here it's
red here and that all that insight I
mean it's literally every breath of air
because you know indigenous wisdom from
around the world is that every single
breath of air every sip of water every
bite of food is a connection to source
as a connection to where we all come
from and so when we have our breaths of
air that are fresh and you can feel that
they're fresh and you're literally
living longer you're more connected when
it's when it's a high concentration of
all different types of particulate in
the air that can be causing us to live
less healthy day by day and also
longevity-wise that need that probably
should be tackled especially when
there's billions of people on the planet
that are living in places that are not
optimal ocean air style quality and so
how do we how do we make that happen
it's like you could view it as a if as
we were building all of the artificial
cities that are now metropolis is that
we cram billions of people into that at
least now like we if we had the
foresight this idea of redesigning
civilization or this idea of reefs
immolating a civilization how would it
be more optimal well make it so that
we're all breathing fresh air that
there's more space for our ecology
agriculture and ecology and architecture
that there's more space there's more
ways for communities to get together all
these types of ideas about it so that's
another good one do you guys have other
ones that you want to share I love these
yeah we have dozens one of our favorites
is like born and bred in Silicon Valley
it was two engineers they met it out of
MIT and the one comes out here to work
at Palantir and the other comes out to
work at Oracle and it turns out - Aziz
they both grew up with refugees in their
families or recently emigrated to the US
and during the Muslim ban they went to
the airports like so many of their
friends and translated for folks but
then they had to go back to work and
they realized that translation doesn't
have to happen in person you could use
technology to unlock bilingual
translators who could provide real-time
services to people in need and so that's
what they did they and a few of their
friends went home and they rolled out a
very quick app on Facebook messenger
that connected bilinguals with the
world's refugees to do things like
border crossing translation for basic
health care for legal services or just
to get questions answered
whoa what's it called its called thar
Gimli thar Gimli Gimli which means
translate to me in several languages
Gimli yeah and they have real stories
about how this is working one of the
stories they tell is that a woman who is
at our Gimli volunteer was at her
apartment in LA when she got a ping from
Turkey Emily whoa and there was a boat
of Syrian refugees that had capsized off
the coast of Turkey but the NGO that
came to rescue them was a Greek NGO and
they didn't speak Turkish and the
Turkish Coast Guard didn't speak Greek
so they fired up charge Emily one of the
refugees had downloaded it before the
journey and she was able to negotiate
getting the boat safely into harbor in
Turkey between Turkish and Greek so that
the two could work together on helping
the Syrians yep
Wow yeah exactly you know she's like
sitting on her couch in LA and she
she's just answering it via video chat
its real-time impact it's the kind of
thing that you know given these
technologists backgrounds they could
have they could do anything in the world
really they can work or Palantir at
Oracle they can work for any tech
company but they are so committed to
this issue because it they have lived
experience with what it means to be a
refugee in this country but they want to
help any refugee out in the world you
said a lot of organizations and I know
you talk about a lot on the show but it
ultimately it's about connecting people
it's about connecting people it's
information it's about connecting people
to each other and so we see that a lot
with the organizations that we help and
that leverage technology focused on
their social impact oh my gosh this
example of of just like taking engineers
that are already like just brilliant and
putting them towards like solving it
sounds like tar jim lee i think it's so
cool because the talent exists around
the world it's just that how do we get
the right resources allocated to make it
so that people are excited and
incentivize how do we correct the
perverse incentives that draw people
away from solving these social impact
problems but how do we create incentives
that inspire people to tackle these
problems fast forward acceleration is
one of them also just new mentalities
around prizes like this could be
something interesting incentivize prizes
for people to to do like social impact
work yeah I'm interested here yeah it
doesn't require a prize and this has
been like my my biggest takeaway story
can be enough people are desperate for
meaning yeah and those people are in
tech companies they're on the streets
they're in every community of the world
you know I'm the social impact half of
our duo here and I did not expect in the
beginning that tech companies and tech
employees would be some of our biggest
advocates they are chomping at the bit
to volunteer with these organizations
they're giving their money they're
giving their time they're giving their
products to make sure that they're
building really powerful tools that have
positive impact in the world it's an
alternative narrative to tech that we
just aren't hearing enough so one day
per week that the major tech companies
give their employees to go and work on
projects that are like teknon profits
and they want to partner with you two
because the people that work there I do
still think a lot of it is just talent
retention based so that they want to
retain the talent that works there by
offering that day to go do that stuff
but also then the talent realizes that
like whoa there could be so much more
meaning by working on something here
rather than this incremental tiny
improvement that is only influencing a
certain Escalon of social economic
status well you could really learn
something right like we have a volunteer
his name is a manual clue
he works at Google he is on the site
reliability engineering team one of the
things that site reliability engineers
do right is make sure that the systems
don't go down yeah like that's very
important for Google folks and you need
clear architecture to know how to do
that but that's not the kind of thing
like you learn in school right it's
something that you would learn on the
job but Google's not letting anyone
touch their architecture that is a
surprise caf so emmanuel volunteered for
fast-forward met a bunch of our teams
and realized oh they actually need
architecture maps so they can
open-source their code and people more
people could help them so he got all
that I mean all of his co-workers to
start volunteering to map out the
architecture of fast forward companies
what does that mean map out your are
like this is how this product connects
to this product this is where this data
source comes from they're literally
putting a map so that you could then
open-source your code and people could
contribute to different parts of it so
like how one of the companies relates to
another one of the companies in terms of
their code bases in terms of what their
offerings are and so then they could
maybe draw a certain technology pieces
from each other and then other
nonprofits from around the world could
help it's kind of from a site
reliability perspective you know the
architecture maps make it easier I
didn't if I were the problems are
because you can
like where something might be broken and
how it's impacting other things in the
system but for the entrepreneurs who
have started organizations it's a super
helpful tool to have to say like oh
we're not like it's not just one massive
thing you know bundle of Technology
here's all the components on the how
they fit together
and individuals can participate and
contribute to the area that like where
they have the expertise so they feel
like they can have the biggest impact or
whatever of the different components is
currently the bottleneck for the
organization so it's really just a way
of like breaking down what might sound
like you know common 'lets literacy tool
or what times like intelligence engine
and the different components that make
it work so that the other so it makes it
easier for other people to get involved
okay yeah we keep making more sense okay
I wonder where that can be applied to
all of Civilizations knowledge just yeah
where it can be applied to make it so
that the architecting of the different
pieces of Technology and and businesses
and when I look at just a good way to
put it is like where can a new erupted
emerging technology be at play with
synergizing with an existing one just
things like that I I like that a lot
okay what about on in terms of like a
future of fast forward what does it look
like it's gonna be happening is going to
just be continuing to accelerate
economic profits from around the world
is there gonna be other things that you
embark on that you think ya can help
move this forward faster we really
believe that our biggest social problems
deserve the best possible technology and
the social good startups are one of the
best ways to create technology that is
truly built for the customer that has
been ignored by market models and so
we're working on a number of ways in
which we can help social good startups
scale and some of that involves will
continue to run the accelerator we also
have
a summit called accelerate good global
nice it happens every spring it's the
largest gathering of technical feats and
philanthropists and tech companies that
care about social good accelerate good
global yes and we have a fund in which
we are passing philanthropic capital
through to tech nonprofits ok so our
good global is happening in the spring
every year and it just might do the
locations change around the world ours
again we make them come to us ok
Francisco cool maybe we can do some
partnership interviews with it yeah with
the different leadership that comes
there in the spring because we love what
how you
I love the sentence you said that the
the social the biggest social problems
in the world deserve the best technology
that's a great way to view this your
essence is I like that a lot
yeah ok and so then there's also a fun
so anyone that's interested in
philanthropic Li donating can donate to
the fund and then you guys allocate that
money for the social impact yeah and it
can have quite quite the ripple effect
we recently worked with HPE foundation
and they gave each of their 60,000
employees $25 to allocate to a curated
list of tech nonprofits sweet and
unlocked over a million bucks and
thousands of HPE employees all over the
world got to be a part of the stories of
these organizations and who they will
become in the months and years ahead oh
yeah that's a great way to do it too
it's just like getting that I get 25
bucket Oken from the major company that
you work with so they put in a million
split up up into these tokens that each
employee feels like they're contributing
to the cause of their choice that are as
on the tech nonprofit list that's also
really interesting one if we can get
more of the massive tech giants around
the world to do stuff like that that's
another way to Excel they're really
empowering their employees to make the
decision yeah yeah instead of just
giving it they get to empower their
employees it's not just the philanthropy
team it's
every employee who gets a very
democratic say and how the company is
spending its philanthropic dollars and
tech workers get it
tech workers understand the potential
for scale and efficiency that comes from
technology really in a way that maybe
others in the world haven't quite seen
it yet and so there is this like - like
that maybe you care deeply homelessness
is your core issue there are tech
nonprofits that are addressing
homelessness perhaps education is your
core issue there are technical projects
that are addressing it so it allows
these tech workers all over the world to
participate in an ecosystem that you
know the products they're building in
their day job are also part of yeah tech
skills incredibly well and yet to be
able to get it targeting the biggest
social challenges I love this so the big
philanthropic fund getting companies of
all that the summit that's happening
every year in the spring here and then
continuing to run the accelerator five
companies a batch once now it's
companies it's up to ten so you went
from five to ten so it kind of went like
five and then like six seven eight per
year like every year you've upped it by
one company ish congratulations as mask
yeah Wow okay so up to ten now so you're
also looking to identify new non
nonprofit tech companies around the
world so if people have identified that
from their local communities worldwide
they can submit it through the website
no info @ ffw org have to info info @
ffw d org for the submissions okay cool
and if you are a tech4good enthusiast or
a tech4good attack worker we have a
facebook community it's called the
global tech nonprofit community where
new technology and asking for help if
people are giving advice and support to
help scale these really cool social good
ideas whoa
so then also individual tech workers can
join that community and then they can
donate their time and resource to
helping the different nonprofits okay
cool Wow great work you built out a
bunch your different streams of ways to
achieve the goals that you're going for
wish I loved that nice so when this is
that when is it the batch start the next
one or were you know we're in the middle
of it you're in the middle of the one
okay
and so there's ten but you're currently
incubating right now okay okay so those
two that you gave us at the end we're
both in this thank yous open Akio is in
the current batch there's a group called
almost fun SAT they just launched this
week which is great content to teach
Betsy T is in fact almost follow yeah to
teach low-income kids how to do well on
the test
oh sweet yeah and they're starting with
the SAT but they will have a whole suite
of tests that they're teaching
low-income on kids from under-resourced
schools how to compete well how to
compete well on those on the bigger test
I'm standardized so on the center ISS
nice so it's also in this batch almost
fun SAT you know that's a great branding
because the kids will be like yeah I
aligned with that that's that's right
cuz it's not you can't just say fun SAT
fun standardized testing yeah almost fun
is yeah yeah interesting and then okay
so then when does so the submission
process is already starting for next
year as well people can submit any time
for next year yeah in fact we believe
our role on the planet is to help create
an ecosystem to support tech nonprofits
so we have a lot of services for groups
that are not currently in our
accelerator from our Facebook community
to a weekly email which sends funding
resources and prize information and
press opportunities for any tech
nonprofit globally we want more of these
we really believe that is the key to
unlocking scaled impact yeah reason
creating a playbook for aspiring
entrepreneurs it'll feel like I don't
know where to start and have questions
about what it means to use tech focused
on impact
nice nice of playbook so for those that
don't necessarily know how to endeavor
into tech nonprofit themselves that they
can start from step one through reading
dating right it sounds a little
intimating tech nonprofit well how do I
do that yeah yeah yeah yeah and then how
do i pair that with one of the greatest
like SDGs or everyone of the massive
social challenges on the planet
yeah not an incremental improvement for
those already wealthy but yeah the
bigger stuff so they now be a component
of it too pairing the tech helping them
pair it with the biggest social
challenges in the playbook
I think so I mean reality is most
entrepreneurs find us already with some
something that they can't let go of
right there are you either growing offer
for directors this is the only thing
that this is what they're calling is in
life and so most of them have gotten to
the point of maybe Matt being into the
problem but they don't know what the
practical steps are then to do it move
it forward and the PlayBook of isn't it
to help them tackle those those
incremental steps towards getting a
momentum that they want to see nice in
tentatively like so next year ish you're
thinking on the playbook yes nice nice
we look forward to Coe promoting that
with you and getting more people excited
about technology sauce 'm and tackling
the biggest social challenges i want to
ask you guys a couple questions on the
way out that we typically ask our guests
we went over all those different options
of getting people involved we have
gotten a better idea about your ethos
and essence it's been a lot of fun do
you guys think that that we come from
somewhere beyond this physical world
into these bodies to play on the planet
I don't know I'm open to the idea but
mostly I wish we were just playing nice
or together and like the things that
keep me up at night is more about how if
this is a simulation how we are
interacting within it today mmm and you
know we call ourselves impatient
optimists in part because like I believe
we can do better and I cannot wait to
get going on it
likewise I love that it's first time I
heard impatient optimist one that's like
hardcore just executing the future that
they want to live in fast and
effectively yeah yeah or live in the now
I want to live in we're live here is
enough craziness happening that we you
know that is a life's work yeah yeah
yeah I don't know that well no I don't
know if it's in our capacity in our
consciousness to be able to
differentiate between what's real what's
the dream actually when I sat down
myself oh yeah this thing over here yeah
dreams won't work unless you do yeah and
so yeah it doesn't say reality won't
work as we do you know like does it
matter what's the reality what's the
dream I don't know that's a good
question but I feel like regardless so
we need to we decided we wanted to work
on these challenges try to make it
better yeah yeah so you see the the
reality that you are immersed in right
now has all of the things that you want
it to be better
and so you dedicate your lives to to
that yeah likewise likewise with the
with the show as well as taking all the
people that come on it and helping them
shine at what they're doing to up to
make those updates in the world so
now does it does it feel like we all
come from a single source does it feel
like we all come from the same origin
I think it can I think part of what's
interesting to me is like there's this
idea that consciousness will bring us
all together and like peace and harmony
but sometimes going to look out into the
world even like the non-human world like
nature the sources that came before us
that we evolved from are also like
pretty brutal the way that like species
have evolved and what comes after that
particular animal often is a predator to
themselves so I don't know part of me
wonders if the the oneness necessarily
means or is consistent with like the
view of kindness or that like everything
is always peaceful peaceful you know and
software people are always like out
fixing bugs and then there's this phrase
that you know is something about or is
it a feature and so it could be that the
way that the system works the oneness
works where things are sometimes kind
but not always kind is not just above
but it could be a feature of progress
for this oneness that we only a little
bit understand so it's like viewing the
artistic expression of source or God as
it having the exact way that it's
supposed to be because if it was all
just peace and love then it would there
wouldn't be the other aspect of that
duality that makes it so beautiful which
is all of the bugs or are they features
that then have to be tended to that have
to be updated that give us a purpose or
a meaning to go and tend to maybe
something like that I mean our time is
just a point in time and
as you mentioned there's like 100
billion people that have come before us
there will be billions of billions more
to come after and maybe were just a step
a step along that way yeah that's what I
don't know what's gonna come next as we
can't see in front of us that deep time
perspective is critical for kids and
adults to get that there yeah even the
smartest ones can only see behind they
can really see see forward right not
real our offices in the Presidio
yeah that's seem forward right video is
the home base of Yoda yeah Yoda is
famous for his perspective 900 years of
perspective he could bring to the world
yet you couldn't see the encroachment of
the dark side so sometimes it's hard to
see where things are going yeah yeah
there's a lot of room for the dark side
right now and it seems like it's coming
through the the bodies of people that
are not as spiritually whole so if
there's a fragmentation in people's
essence and their spirit then there's a
room for malevolence
to come through it and be at play on the
planet and so to work on one's own true
connection to nature
to source as well as one's connection to
their own North Star and what brings
them meaning every day it it removes the
space needed for malevolence to
potentially come through so you know
we've been working a lot with indigenous
wisdom and trying to help integrate and
synthesize that into Silicon Valley
technology you know Shan Jen's coming up
London's Tel Aviv there's so many of
these little hubs around the world that
are coming up Africa's about to erupt in
population and creativity and so just
like how do we not only go there and
provide them with the material like the
Amazon versus Alibaba source like
providing them a toothpaste and
toothbrushes and socks and all that
stuff but underwear but how do we
effectively not make a Scramble for
Africa
version two and how do we make it
instead a maximize the creative
potential of the people that are coming
through there so all these styles of
thinking and questions is you know what
we are so passionate about on the
program you kind of touched on this a
little bit but are we in a simulation I
guess the way we touched on before is I
don't know if we'll never know if so I'm
very curious what's outside of it but in
the meantime we're impatient optimists
and taking what may just be a dream but
playing a role of trying to bring tech
I'm focusing it not just on these
business problems but also on social
impact in helping people love a little
bit better yeah right like one of the
things that's so powerful about spending
your summer with these entrepreneurs who
could do anything but they've chosen to
work on these social problems is that
like what is key is that they're
grounded in this love of humanity and
how do you unlock and scale that and
it's a powerful space to be in so I
don't know if it's a simulation or not
but I
I like some of the features that are in
it yeah things that they're baked in a
lot of potential yeah in a way the rules
yes yeah that's up to us to figure what
we do I'm very curious about your own
relationships with your higher selves do
you guys feel like you're connected
spiritually something that is greater
than yourselves
I do I was raised Catholic so this like
grounding and social justice is very
core to how I show up in the world and
understanding that like this is this is
just temporary and I have a
responsibility as a human who gets to be
on the planet to make it better in any
way that I can mm-hmm and that's one of
the reasons like when we work with all
these volunteers and we work with these
folks like I see them seeking meaning
and looking for opportunities to unlock
that meaning and that feels like very
universal you may not have to you may
not agree with who my higher power but I
see them seeking a better way to be on
yeah I think I manifest itself to me
most often like in beauty so that could
be like the creation of life like a kid
getting born or like sunrises and
sunsets yeah but some moments like those
like looking at the Stars you think
about like how expansive
it is and how small of a blip you know
we may be in time and in space compared
to everything else that's out there
mmm you know those are great then and
that answers our most beautiful thing in
the world question then what about you
Shannon where's what's the most
beautiful thing in the world one of the
things that's really fun about running a
non-profit is that you spend a lot of
time thanking people like that is one of
your core responsibilities is to be in
the world expressing gratitude for the
generosity and kindness and wisdom that
they that folks give to the thing that
you're working on and so it's one of the
things I think is most beautiful in the
world is that the opportunity to
recognize when something truly good has
happened and to express gratitude for
the human being and the entities that
enabled it it's a it's an amazing gift
and then that's your day job it's like
it's awesome yeah yeah gratitude is so
powerful humility is another one that's
so powerful
Quinny midi nuance these types of words
that if we embody on a daily basis can
help us so much this has been such a
beautiful conversation you two thank you
for coming on the show thank you for
having a thank you for talking thank you
yeah yeah it's so great thank you
likewise it really grateful thank you
thank you for all your incredible work
both of you and thanks for seeing her
behind the scenes as well thank you very
much video audience yeah it's also to
ory Shapiro for producing thank you very
much or to also everyone thank you so
much for watching we greatly appreciate
it we'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking also check out
the links in the bio below to fast
forward check out their twitter also
check out kevin Shannon's LinkedIn
profiles and have more conversation for
your friends your co-workers people
online about so on social media about
the conversations that we had about
today talk more about accelerating
technology for social impact and how to
get involved in the myriad of ways that
we talked about today and also support
the artists entrepreneurs the
organizations the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe and
support them help them grow help them
increase their impact all of our links
to our show simulation are below to our
patreon our cryptocurrency link our
PayPal link you can design cool merch
you get paid all those links are below
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you very much for tuning in and we
will see you soon